وقد اخذتنا ايضا نجوان سمري من هناك الياس
بسماع دوي انفجارات قويه في محيطي تل ابيب
جاءت ذلك بعد انطلاق هذه الرشقات
الصاروخيه من قطاع غزه باتجاه المناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه
في القطاع اذا لا ادري ان كانت نجوان سمري
معنا من تل ابيب الان نجوان هل انت معنا
نعم ايمان اسمعك
ذوي انفجارات قويه في محيط تل ابيب اذا
كما افتن هل هل اتضحت الصوره
نعم يعني من الموقع الذي نتواجد به سمعنا
قبل دقائق قليله فقط عده انفجارات قويه
هنا في محيط مدينه تل ابيب ولكن سافرت
الانذار دوت ايضا في مدينه تل ابيب وفي
عده مدن اخرى تقع الى شمال تل ابيب في
رماد جان وايضا في المدن التي تقع في
الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه تل ابيب اذا هي
رشقه صاروخيه باتجاه عده مدن في مركز
اسرائيل في تل ابيب الكبرى ما يعرف بمنطقه
تل ابيب الكبرى وهي مدينه تل ابيب والمدن
المحاذيه لها من جهه الشمال وجهات الجنوب
ايضا اذا هي سافرات انذار كانت في تل ابيب
في رامات جان في حلون وفي باتيام وريشون
قبل قليل سمعنا صافرات انذار من هذا
الموقع حيث نتواجد